when was it and even maybe from your
pops did that drive you guys to compete
against each other or that the Dr did
that drive you guys to compete against
the world I I don't think it's something
that we learned from my father my father
my father didn't have a brother I think
it's something that happened organically
and it's not so much competition against
each other in terms of what I can do and
he can it's more like how much am I
going to contribute to the team that you
don't a perfect example this house is
set up literally perfect perfect for it
there's an exercise we hate doing you
put 30 kilograms on a burpee bar do the
on a weight bar you do a burpee lift it
above your head and you do 150 times
it's tiring it's horrible so I'll do
them and I'll say you know Andrew you're
a why haven't you done them yet
then he'll do them and then I'll go do
them again just because I know of I do
him he has to do it that's not people
could see it as two men competing
against each other or you can see it as
two men within the same house getting
stronger and pushing each other to
become stronger